ich habe als kontrast seriöse krawatte
angezogen heute um auch mal nein erst
sein ich habe mich beworben ich bin
nicht die ausschaltung der letzten runde
gekommen
krieg krisensteuer schock ist das das
richtige zeichen
vorab ich finde wenn zwei menschen sich
lieben wenn es ein zeichen gibt für die
liebe für die zukunft für kinder für
familie dann ist das immer ein zeichen
wert alles prima alles paletti die
beiden haben sich am heutigen tage vor
einigen jahren kennengelernt wollten
gerne diesen termin machen deshalb gab
es diesen termin das was ganz anderes
ist es ob man das in dieser form feiert
da kann man ganz unterschiedlicher
ansicht sein ob man ist eine brief ein
privates fest öffentlich mit kanzler und
anderen minister feiert darüber kann man
alles diskutieren grundsätzlich finde
ich erst mal ein zeichen für die liebe
für gehen dafür zukunft ist immer gut
gerade in diesen zeiten kann das
überhaupt nicht schaden das andere ist
eben
muss es öffentlich zelebriert werden
muss es mit pomp zelebriert werden da
kann man unterschiedlicher meinung sein
am ende spricht für diese hochzeit finde
ich auch noch dass christian den heute
nicht im bundestag war und seine stimme
nicht frau ackermann als unabhängige
antidiskriminierungs beauftragte geben
könnte jede stimme die da fehlte ist
eine gute stunde schreibst du jetzt ein
bisschen ab vor dem thema ja auch
vielleicht gleich diskutiert aber jetzt
erstmal hier die frage auch an die runde
es ist ein gutes zeichen kann man
einfach die liebe feiern oder sollte man
als finanzminister sagen auch jetzt in
diesen krisenzeiten verschiedener noch
mal so in ein wobei drei jahre erst mal
von meiner seite her finanzminister und
trocken finanzministerin frau alles
lieber alles gute viel kraft viel
gesundheit und vor allen dingen starke
nerven beim bund der liebe vor allem mit
einem finanzminister das ist das eine
aber die frage ist natürlich ungeheuer
an die lieben sich ist vollkommen okay
ja das können sie aber die frage ist
immer wie das können sie nämlich ob bei
sag mal bei würstchen und kartoffelsalat
oder man macht das halt etwas dekadenter
und das zeichen und das ist ja die
menschen auf sylt die aufs leben alleine
schon auf sylt zu heiraten da ist es
denn nun mal nicht billig ist meiner
meinung nach in dieser krise unseres
landes als finanzminister der ja viele
dinge auch mit zu verantworten hat
einfach vielleicht eine nummer oder eine
schippe zu hoch aber sind sollen die
menschen sich
entscheiden ich finde man hätte es soll
ja heiraten aber vielleicht nicht so
nicht mehr den ganzen punkt nicht mit
den ganzen anderen daten zusammen dann
kann man auch alles etwas kleiner machen
man muss es da sind wir wieder beim
thema ein vorbild verhält sich
vorbildlich und wenn man etwas von
menschen von bürgern in unserem land
fordert dann muss man sich vorbildlich
verhalten ist vormachen er ist nur ein
beispiel von vielen
damit kein gutes vorbild ist es eine
schippe zu viel was der finanzminister
an grill stehen und ein paar bockwürste
wänden also die hochzeit feiern ich
glaube dass probleme sollte er steht in
der öffentlichkeit es ist glaube ich in
dem moment auch egal wir es macht macht
das so gemacht dass sowas wird immer
falsch sondern
aber vielleicht wollte man sich nochmal
pr berater im moment leisten oder so und
sagen was wäre denn vielleicht sinnvoll
gerade ich meine die bilder zwar jetzt
nicht so super pompöser von nicht
was danach kam also auf der einen seite
ja auch ein privatleben und
vielleicht ist es an der zeit auch lasst
ihn doch den moment einfach mal machen
und wenn er der meinung ist dass so
supertoll zu machen dann muss man sich
vielleicht in drei jahren vier jahren
wenn die nächste mal dass auch mal daran
erinnern außerdem wird das entchen aus
baden war er produziert wird die bilder
die in der letzten satireshow einem um
die ohren gehauen werden wenn er
demnächst wieder von schuldenbremse
redet oder irgendwas zusammen streichen
wände wird man den ganzen abend in
dauerschleife dann diese bilder sehen
muss man sich überlegen ob man als
politiker solche bilder produziert also
debatte ziemlich daneben man kann sich
doch einfach mal freuen ich finde das so
schön die beiden haben sich gefunden das
noch mal ein schönes zeichen auch gerade
in so einer schwierigen zeit wenn zwei
leute die sich lieben und dann auch
heiraten und natürlich sind beide
personen des öffentlichen lebens da ist
auch ein interesse daran sehen mich
interessiert ist doch auch das ist doch
völlig normal und das wird dann auch die
möglichkeit hamper bilder zu sehen ich
finde es schön und ich gratuliere den
wald von herzen ich freue mich
wahnsinnig für die beiden und ich finde
man muss auch mal gönnen können also
habt warum warum müssen wir solche
debatten führen um eine horn richtig
aber sie müssen das ist endlich
verstehen dass
ihr präsident der präsident
dann können wir doch den menschen aber
auch dass sie vielleicht warm duschen
oder dass sie sich aufs mal
stück brot kaufen das problem ist die
kennzahl nicht sie sollen den gürtel
enger schnallen wir sollen auch like
wäre nützlich sagt wir sollen weniger
fleisch essen wo seine eigene tat denn
ein fetter timos stieg so fällt mal so
groß gerade bei instagram postet schon
bisschen komisch aber immer wieder
vorbilder machen es vor ich glaube das
hat meine stimme zu erheben weil ich
seit neun jahren 365 tage im jahr für
den kinderschutz eintrete und dinge
sehen die wir alle nicht sehen wollen
deswegen habe ich meine stimme als
bürger als freier bürger und vertreter
von millionen von menschen wenn zum
kinderschutz nicht muss sagen ich habe
sie gedacht ich fand auch die frage ist
muss ich ihn erst recht dann dachte ich
also was geht in einem fall es überhaupt
diese frage stellen welches unglück muss
man eigentlich in sich tragen um
überhaupt die frage zu stellen darf der
das
gleichzeitig musste ich mich dann selbst
überprüfen auch wenn ich so wirklich
findet auch jetzt haben alle schon
gratulieren aber auch von mir noch mal
glück wünsche dem brautpaar das spielt
es keine rolle ob ich jetzt gratuliere
nicht aber aber natürlich auch wenn ich
dann an sie denke mit welchen menschen
sie in kontakt stehen was ihnen die
menschen schildern und mich in die
menschen ein versetzte was denkt die oma
die jetzt das brot und genauigkeit
verfügen das gegeneinander aufwiegen
freuen zu dürfen dass jemand sein glück
findet dass menschen gemeinsam bereits
in ihren lebensweg zu gehen das ist doch
toll
in die pläne diskutieren das ist doch
das aber nicht wohlfühlen und rissen und
wenn doch jemand heiratet der sein leben
lang politik dafür gestaltet dass
menschen mehr chancen bekommen dass noch
mehr menschen mehr chance bekommt das
ist das ist der kern der dna die
liberale antreibt das hat mit bildung zu
tun das hat auch mit der möglichkeit zu
tun wirtschaftlichen ausstieg zu haben
das hat damit zu tun tatsächlich auch in
seiner gesellschaft sein glück finden zu
können wenn so wie man an so einem tag
heiratet und wie ein schönes bild haben
dann lass uns doch einfach mal einfach
mal glücklich sein woran ich will bloß
ein paar aale drum herum etwas kleiner
halten in so einer krise unseres landes
das ist das was ich mit demut sagen muss
ich stehe an gräbern ich habe diese dame
im arm gehabt das ist das was die leben
die parade das ist auch das müsste kann
weder wie aus den medien sagen das ist
ein gewinn take die menschen
interessiert die bilder wollen sie sehen
der finanzminister heirate das ist unser
finanzminister natürlich wollen die
menschen die bilder sehen also ich
glaube diese parade von der sie sprechen
ist es nicht nur hausgemacht vom
brautpaar dass sie sagen komm bitte alle
herbei so viele wie es nur geht damit
wir die bilder haben ich könnte mir
sogar vorstellen dass sie derzeit
gefragt waren deswegen bist du nicht
eingeladen weil du hättest diese parade
einfach sind so viele kollegen vor uns
vor ort zwingend dazu gehöre ich habe
auch mal gerne wochenende so aber es ist
in der tat eine zweischneidige
geschichte es gibt sehr viele leute die
sich sehr wenig leisten können und
trotzdem mit hingabe die royals gucken
oder solche hochzeiten gucken und sich
mit freunden vielleicht gar nicht
gekommen sondern vielleicht sich auch
eine andere welt träumen wie immer man
das bewerten mag also es ist ist es
komplizierter aber
ich habe eigentlich auch kein problem
damit ich wollte nur sagen dass ich das
zeichen immer in den jederzeit richtig
finde und zu zeiten der größten
katastrophen haben die leute geheiratet
und sich geliebt und das ist natürlich
ein wert an sich erstmal irgendwie geht
das leben weiter und das
können und das sind romantische worte
von ralf schoula damit geben wir in
allen richtungen was zum treuen weg ist